l'entrée des talibans dans kaboul a pris
tout le monde par surprise et où les
puissances étrangères donnait encore au
moins quelques mois au gouvernement
d'ashraf ghani hackman mali ouassou de
lui le frère du défunt et mythique
commandant massoud était coincé à ce
moment là dans un avion qui s'apprêtait
à quitter kaboul pour islamabad tout
aussi choquée de la rapidité de la chute
du gouvernement la veille à peine ils
étaient réunis avec quelques 200
combattants chez lui à faire des plans
les talibans n'ont pas gagner
l'afghanistan on leur a plutôt servi sur
un plateau d'argent accuse-t-il de
parole
celui qui a été ambassadeur de son pays
à l'ombre il dirige aujourd'hui la
fondation massoud dans la mémoire de son
frère laisse une porte ouverte à la
discussion avec les talibans sans trop y
croire ils misent plutôt sur le combat
de son clan porté par ahmad masood le
fils du légendaire commandant massoud à
quelques jours du 20e anniversaire de
l'assassinât de celui que l'on appelait
le lion du panchir le jeune homme de 32
ans se glisse dans les sillages laissé
par son père il s'est retranché dans la
forteresse naturelle qui est la vallée
du panjshir et affirment ils préparent
et la résistance aux talibans il dit
souhaiter la paix mais être prêt à la
guerre des propos auxquels son oncle et
beau-père fait écho
l'arsenal et la force de frappe dont ils
disposent sont incertains sans doute
modeste mais ce n'est pas que la sphère
des armes dit il il s'agit de la lutte
de toute une société qui a été
transformée par les vingt dernières
années
si les algues ont changé croit l'âme les
talibans pas du tout non
le chanteur notre batteur des
collaborateurs
evans leurs structures et leurs
principaux
alors que les forces étrangères
s'empresse de mettre fin aux opérations
d'évacuation pour ne plus revenir ahmad
wali massoud tient à leur servir un
avertissement
ce que son frère affirme être grandes
puissances occidentales il n'y a plus de
20 ans ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada
paris